comment les autochtones peuvent-ils
sortir gagnant d'une élection alors jeff
pour répondre à ta question comment les
autochtones peuvent sortir gagnant d'une
élection c'est un petit peu difficile
parce qu'on a vu la dernière élection
avant celle ci est long on avait
l'impression de sortir gagnant d'une
élection pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps mais bien sûr on fait
attention on fait toujours attention aux
promesses qu'on nous donne parce que une
psy pendant dans l'historique canadiens
de ne pas respecter ses promesses l'a
d'ailleurs beaucoup de côtés ont pas été
respectés beaucoup de promesses
électorales n'ont pas été respectées et
là c'était cette année c'était un petit
peu le l'élection je dirais du
mécontentement justement de ces
promesses non tenues comment pourrait-on
en sortir le gagne on prend en sortir
gagnant c'est justement le gouvernement
qui viennent se faire réélire qui a été
justement critiqué beaucoup pour son
approche des questions autochtones pour
ses promesses non tenues aussi pour la
gestion de certaines crises avec
certains ministres justement autochtone
de ne pas laisser tenter
sa relation future part je commence
cette expérience ou ce qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
manquements mais justement en apprenant
et en décidant de renforcer justement
leur désir de réconciliation leur désir
de renforcer les relations avec les
premières nations
est ce que cette élection là qu'on va
voir le nouveau cabinet est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il y aura pas de ministres
autochtone à des rôles importants
où est ce qu'on va éviter justement
d'aller dans des grandes pompes dire on
a un ministre autochtone voilà et de se
rendre compte que ça implique quelque
chose de plus grand que je sais est un
cabinet libéral ou un cabinet
conservateur s'est carrément quelqu'un
qui représente le pont entre une
communauté autochtone qui n'est pas
nécessairement touchée par toutes les
choses que le glas être un manque de la
population canadienne peut toucher mais
qui est quand même touché par toutes les
décisions que le gouvernement fédéral et
provincial peut faire en son nom donc
quand on est gagnant
je dirais que c'est quand il ya une
prise de conscience
et quand il ya aussi un mais recule pas
des fois de décisions des choix qui ont
été pris et quand il ya une écoute qui
se fait des premières nations
donc on va le voir présentement pour les
quatre prochaines années à quel point on
a perdu on a gagné nos élections et ça
va peut-être demander justement à un
plus grand réveil de la population
autochtone d'avoir quelque chose qui
nous représente réellement sur le futur
l échiquier politique fédérale et
provinciale donc pas uniquement de la
consultation mais carrément des membres
de gouvernements indépendants et
autochtone pour parler des enjeux
autochtones
alors merci beaucoup pour ta question
james j'espère pouvoir en recevoir
d'autres de votre part sur ces enjeux là
et n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer ça à
paroles autochtone